hey everyone its Joanna here this is a
requested video from quite a number of
you asking me how is it possible to live
healthy on a really tight budget well
let me tell you first of all that it is
very possible and I am just like most of
you I am living on a budget myself you
might need to do a little bit more
planning a little bit more research but
with all this work put into it it will
be wanted and you will be able to live
healthy and also to loose weight if that
is your goal so I'm going to share with
you my top 20 tips on how to eat healthy
on a tight budget
the first tip as you can see from my
groceries here is to forget about bread
buy generic bread or store brands raw
food like rice pasta frozen vegetables
tastes the same just like your friend
and friends are there but what you're
saving is a lot of money because you're
saving on the nice fancy packaging from
the Brenda brands that you get a
marketer once told me the supermarket
places their most profitable products
within your I levels so if the products
targeted at you it will be around the
middle shelves if it's targeted towards
the kids it will be at the lower shelves
value products with less fancy packaging
are always placed right at the bottom of
the shelves so when you're in the
supermarket look right down you'll still
find what you want equally good quality
but it costs way less with less fancy
packaging the second tip is to buy
reduced item or items which our own
sales so if you are really on a tight
budget most supermarkets will reduce
items which are almost expiring
sometimes even up to 90% so go to the
supermarket later at night where they're
always cutting and you avoid lots of
reduced items and
so items on sales another example is I
got this organic canned tomatoes for 50%
discount usually they would cost a lot
more because this item is currently on
sales I would buy them and stock them up
so be wise be smart
do some research do your shopping and
see what items are on sales which are
healthy and you can have them as part of
your daily meals this then leads on to
my third point which is to buy in bulk
so if you know there's a certain product
that you like and it's on sales whether
it's half price or whether it's by 1-3-1
why not buy them in box and store them
up because you know that you will eat
them so I've bought this Tomatoes which
was 50% I got two jars of raspberry jam
which was buy one free one same thing
buy a box of stock camera and also buy
in a larger quantities because they
always cost much
so owes something that is really cheap
is so cheap and we eat them a lot so buy
them in large quantity it will last you
for a long time and it will save you
lots of money as well and the first tip
is something I apply a lot which is to
buy frozen vegetables I know it's not
applicable in Asia because you don't
have frozen vegetables but if you're in
the western country buy frozen
vegetables they are so much more cheaper
and they last you for months if I were
to buy fresh vegetables the trouble is
that I will not be able to finish it on
time
and it will go off and therefore our
threeway always my food therefore I
prefer buying frozen vegetables because
it's much cheaper and last you a long
time and you are still getting all the
nutrients in it you're not losing any
nutrients the vegetables are picked and
then frozen at its peak ripeness so
frozen vegetables still Falls and
contains all of its nutrients and you
will see that I always use frozen
vegetables in my recipes which lead on
to my fifteenth is to pack on vegetables
in comparison to me vegetables are so so
so much more cheaper and they are large
in quantity so why not pack your meals
with lots of vegetables first thing they
will save you money
second thing they were trimmed down your
waistline and that is what we want so
choose to load your meals with lots of
vegetables because they will keep you
satisfied and they were happy to do
sweet at the same time and the next tip
is to buy cheap protein we need protein
of course we need protein but do we
always need expensive protein not in my
case because my favorite proteins are
eggs they're absolutely cheap packed
with protein chicken chicken fillet
much cheaper compared to red needs
saving packed with protein and that's
what you need in order to lose weight
eat healthy and also fish I know these
are Salmons they are more expensive by
you don't have to buy Salmons buy any
other fish which cost less in your
country depending on where you live
there will always be proteins that cost
less so buy cheap protein pack your
meals with this protein they're really
good for your body and trick yourself
occasionally to red meats or proteins
that cost more money
tip number seven is the most important
tip to help you to lose weight which is
to buy whole food and not processed food
think about it most Thai processed food
are not cheap whole food are always much
cheaper for example this chicken breast
would cost me four pounds in comparison
if I were to buy chicken nuggets I would
get very little quantity
filled with salt and processed
ingredients and that would cost me maybe
two two pounds and a half and that would
not even satisfy me so choose to buy
whole food where you're in control of
the ingredients and you can prep the
milk based on how you like it processed
food are not cheap and they are not good
for your health so why waste your money
on processed food if you know you can
get cheaper and better quality food when
you buy whole food the next tip is
something not many people will agree
with me but when you're living on a
budget
forget about organic just go basic of
course it would be great if we all can
afford organic food because they taste
much better and
much healthier for you but hey when
you're living on a budget you know what
you gotta go basic for instance frozen
and basic what I got here is a pack of
frozen and basic berry mix you know what
it makes me great smoothie it's much
cheaper than organic berries and I am
still getting the nutrients and the
health benefits from it so really go
basic these Tomatoes are basic they're
not organic so what you have to make
sure is that you wash them thoroughly
and soak them for at least 30 minutes
before using them and eggs I buy caged
eggs
sorry chickens I don't buy free-range
eggs because caged eggs cost so much
more or less at my focus here is to get
protein out of it
so unfortunately at this moment I cut by
three range eggs so when you're on a
budget
just think basic food what do you want
the protein out of it that's what you
need or the vegetables consumption
that's what you need
eventually if you can afford it of
course by all means go organic but for
now keep it to basic the next tip is
something I practice a lot as well which
is to buy seasonal fruits and vegetables
when you go into the supermarket go with
an open I know what you want unique
vegetables a unique fruit but duty the
specific vegetables and fruits the
answer is no go to the vegetables and
fruits sections see what's in season and
buy the cheapest vegetables and fruits
you can get and change your meal plans
change your food intake according to
what's in season and what cost less this
leads up to my next tip which is to shop
in your local markets
sometimes supermarkets are not always
the cheapest so go to your local markets
and look at the vegetables and fruit
rage they have there most times they
will be much cheaper and much fresher in
comparison to your big supermarkets and
sometimes they have reduced items
they sell impulse for example bananas I
love bananas and whenever it's on reduce
because it's going off soon I will buy
them impulse what I'll do is to slice
them up and freeze them up and use them
later on that's another way to shop
smart and cheap as well tip number 11 is
to eat like the local you will find that
in different countries there are
different types of food that costs way
less for example in Asia tofu is
extremely cheap and it's very easily
accessible so in either in Asia you know
you can always have more tofu if you
want to because it's so cheap
whereas milk and cheese are very cheap
in the West not in Asia you don't have
to stick to my meal plan or to a
particular milk and and try to buy
ingredients that is expensive or it's
not easily accessible in your country so
adjust the plan and use ingredients that
are cheap and easily accessible in your
own country so you want to lose weight
and you want to save money my advice to
you is to write a grocery list and to
stick by it only buy things that you
need not you want so make a list before
you go shopping when you're in the
supermarket gives straight to the
sections and get what you need and go
straight out you don't have to start
looking around stop doing your window
shopping and start being tempted by what
junks they have on sales that will save
you money and that will save your
waistline the next tip is very useful if
you're a student or you live alone and
you want to save money which is to cook
in bulks i've always said this in my
meal plan because you will save your
money it was save your time it's much
more convenient and you are more likely
to stick to your meal plans cook in box
store there in the fridge or freezer and
take it out and warm it up when it's
dinner time this is especially important
if you have just got that from school on
work and you feel it
tired and lazy to cook guess what you've
got a healthy meal in your freezer or
fridge for dinner moving on that is to
learn to store your food sometimes we
buy your box because it's cheap and we
can't finish it and it's going off and
so we need to learn how to start on food
for example what I have here is my
mashed up avocado I could not finish my
avocado
and so I decided to mash it up add a
little bit of lemon and store it in the
freezer so when I feel like spreading it
on my toast I can just take it out let
it thaw and spread it on my toes like I
say most food can be stored in the
freezer just do your research online and
see what you can do and how you can
store it even milks you can even store
milks in the freezer so just do a little
bit of extra homework and see how you
can start your food instead of throwing
it away when it comes to preparing meal
saving money and eating healthy this is
my tip which is to keep it simple simple
meals are healthy bills don't make
complicated meals it takes way too long
it cost too much it's too complicated
and why why the hassle so just pick
simple meals which is good for your body
good for tummy which cost less and just
keep your meals simple and delicious so
that's something I practiced a lot keep
your meals simple with minimal
ingredients pick several ingredients
that you like these are all my favorite
ingredients and consume them most of the
week keep it real simple that way you
will live much healthy as well of course
by all means if you feel like
experimenting with new dishes you can
always do that when you have the time
over the weekends or even when you have
some extra cash my next tip is to cut
your jumps out completely think about it
which is cheaper soda drinks or free
water biscuits which always cost about
150 to 2 pounds or would you rather buy
nuts same price bar which is healthier I
would go from nuts the truth is those
extra money that you spend on buying
jumps every month can either be saved or
you can stop them for healthier much
healthier alternatives so just
completely cut out your jumps it will
help you to save money and it will help
you to look your best the next tip is
something everyone should take advantage
of discount cards coupons cards that
collects point use them for example what
I got here is a Tesco Clubcard every
time I spend I get points and therefore
points turns into coupons and coupons
turn into money saving and I've also got
my nectar card take advantage of these
cards apply for one if you don't have
one they will not consume a single cent
instead they will be saving you lots of
money in a year and many years to come
next point please don't ever buy water I
know there are people are they who buy
water and it costs money over time
especially when you have to drink so
much of water a day stop buying water if
you're one of those people who buy water
invest in one of these filter and start
saving money my second last point is
quantity doesn't always eco quality
sometimes when people shop for food they
always want to buy large quantity
because they think I'm getting value for
my money but it doesn't always equal
quality for example if you were to buy
wholemeal bread it will cost more in
comparison to white bread but form your
bread will fill you up for a much longer
period of time
therefore what you're getting out of it
is not only lots of health benefits but
you will also consume less in comparison
to white bread it will leave you hungry
very quickly therefore you end up
consuming more not good for your health
and it will only lead to weight gain and
also more money being spent so just
remember that quantity doesn't always
equal quality
see what kind of food fills you up even
more and what kind of food is healthier
for you last but not least my last point
everybody knows brown rice is much
healthier for you but it costs way way
way more
than your normal white rice so as you
can see I don't just buy brown rice i
buy white rice as well what you can do
is instead of only consuming white rice
I want to get their health benefit from
my brown rice as well so what I tend to
do what I could is to mix them up this
will help me to save money because I buy
white rice but I am also getting the
benefits from my brown rice plus this is
also a good way to introduce brown rice
into your diet because not many people
like brown rice so mix it up if you cut
before this but you can afford this why
not try to mix it up and therefore
you're getting the health benefit and
you're also saving lots of money so
these are my personal tips to eat
healthy and to live on a budget because
I'm just like you I am living on a bunch
of myself therefore you will notice that
in my meal packs I don't usually use
organic food at all apply these tips
plan a little bit ahead in regards to
the healthy food you need and match that
with your budget you will be able to
live healthy eat healthy lose weight
look good and feel good for new fitness
food and motivational videos please like
share and subscribe to my youtube
channel and website do you follow me on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter
to stay connected with me thanks guys
you